il s'appelle omar myriam et abd el ghany
ils ont 14 15 et 16 ans ils sont
canadiens et de fiers musulman à l'école
comme à la maison le sujet est
inévitable des attentats de paris
beyrouth la violence inouïe des derniers
jours les troubles le monde doit ou
parce que dans certains côtés une vie ça
reste une vie personne a le droit dans
le mur avec quelqu'un d'autre
et puis j'étais sûr car la femme quand
on serait pointé du doigt encore une
fois on va dire c'est l'islam si
l'islande mais l'islam mais prend pas ça
comment expliquer à un jeune de mon âge
ce qui est en train d'arriver dans le
monde parce que vous comprenez pas vous
moi exactement parce que non nous non
plus on ne comprend pas exactement ce
qui est caché derrière tout ça comment
expliquer l'inexplicable
pourtant si jeune ils sentent de plus en
plus besoin de se faire entendre en tant
que mineur on peut pas vraiment vraiment
à interagir avec les médias et où par
exemple par les réseaux sociaux mais à
part ça mais faut des lancers faut
dénoncer
si pour lui c'est naturel pour d'autres
trouver les mots justes c'est moins
évident c'est traumatisant le fait de
penser qu'on est bon parce qu'on est
musulman comme nos parents nous ont
appris et soudainement de devenir au
regard de l'autre de la société
québécoise dans laquelle on vit
potentiellement quelqu'un de méchant
c'est lourd pour un enfant mais les
enfants sont capables
et s'ils sont accompagnés ils sont
capables les enfants sont extrêmement
résilient en fait les gens qui ont fait
là tant qu'appareil sont pas vraiment
des musulmans quand quelqu'un nous
aimons voitures en août musulmans hayat
à 13 ans il a décidé d'écrire sa peine
et sa confusion
kaka lui a délivré et lui a donné deux
hommes lors des deux fois une attaque
terroriste
il ne comprend pas il crée la suite et
il n'est pas le seul avec des amis ils
ont décidé de publier dans les journaux
des lettres de pignons pour exprimer
dans l'eure
mots ce que tant d'autres musulmans nos
rages ressentent ce n'est pas notre
identité a nommé utilise comme l'a dit
jiang et lui vole notre identité et il
fait ils font ça sous le nom de l'islam
sous la bannière de l'islam pour
commettre leurs crimes contre l'humanité
est ce assez lourde pour vivre avec ça
et de me sentir impuissant
un jour j'espère rêver en matière de
l'église ont tous disparu qui a plus de
terreur pendant notre religion notre de
londieu je veux que ça reste a fait de
la peine de voir tout cela ici tous en
parlent aussi ouvertement ce n'est pas
pour se défouler sinon l'avenir de
demain à 15 ans omar dit qu'il veut
avant tout éduquer l'islam prône la paix
l'amour mais cela me dit si ton voisin
ne vont pas pendant des jours tu vas
aller le voir pour voir comment il va
mais c'est vraiment ça se contredit avec
ce que détaille permis de faire il y
convaincu que les jeunes musulmans sont
les mieux placés pour le dire et le
prouver si tu as marre altérer ce
courage au canada montréal
voilà beaucoup parler bien sûr des
auteurs des attentats de paris
nous posons notre regard maintenant sur
les victimes il y en a eu 129 pour les
voir pour les connaître je vous invite à
consulter notre dossier web à l'adresse
que vous voyez à l'écran